foreign
[Music]
no opening gag we're going to cut right
to the point here is the big banner
headline for most of the folks who
aren't regular to my channel
yes I am going to be reviewing the
Doctor Who specials when they come out
no that does not mean a complete
resumption of all the things that I put
on hold in support of the SAG after
strike that's the short version now for
the ramble so I mentioned in the video
that I did talking about how I found out
that doctor who was considered struck
work by sag-aftra so if you are
intending to support sagafter you should
treat it the same as any other stroke
work now there seemed to be some
confusion in the comments I suspect from
people who didn't actually watch the
whole video but to clarify again this
does not mean that the production of
Doctor Who is striking that is being
done under Equity the reason it falls
under strong struck work has actually
nothing to do with the way that show was
made but it has to do with the fact that
the entity being struck against by both
the writers and the actors is the amptp
and the amptp
is an association that ties to the
Doctor Who production short version
whatever doctor who needs to work with
american-based assets be it location
shooting here working with actors that
are in Sag but art inequity they do it
through the amptp and since all
Productions with direct associations to
the amptp are being struck against
that's why Doctor Who is considered
struck work now again different
YouTubers will make their own decisions
on whether or not that affects how they
choose to talk about Doctor Who I said
it was going to make me pause basically
all discussion but I also said in that
video that I was trying to get more
clarification on my specific situation
and what it is that I do since I now
knew for a fact that doctor who was
struck work I really just wanted to know
should I be altering how I'm approaching
struck work because basically
sort of get to the point I have been way
more stringent in what I have decided to
not do to support the strike then
honestly they are asking for or done a
lot of my peers now that's not because I
think I am more morally pure in some way
it has been an overabundance of caution
to be completely Frank I don't want to
screw up and so I'm overdoing it that's
the very short version of that but I did
manage to get a better point of contact
with uh sag-aftra than the one that I
was having trouble with before and I got
a very clear answer uh to my very
specific situation laying out my
concerns which basically spawned from
the fact that even though some of what I
do is very much review material the
overall description of my job isn't
really reviewer it's content creator but
for the purposes of sag aftershrike they
would file me under influencer and the
guidelines for influencer are different
than the guidelines for critics and
reviewers so I felt very much that while
I could probably defend my doing reviews
I really want a clarification from them
that they would look at the work in
isolation and not look at who it was
coming from that if the work qualified
as a review it didn't matter that the
person doing it might otherwise be
considered an influencer as far as
they're concerned and the short answer
to that is yeah that is exactly the
answer answer I got back and this is
clarification I needed frankly I needed
it to feel comfortable again not because
like I want to do this better than all
like I just get really paranoid about
misinterpreting things and about making
an assumption that it turns out that was
not uh the correct assumption to make so
I really strive on Clarity with these
things and now that I've gotten it
review content is viable so in case any
other content creators on here are
wondering what the answer I got back was
uh I'll even read you directly from the
most relevant thing because basically
they say anything that is genuine review
is fine and they do make some
clarification as to what wouldn't be
considered a genuine review by genuine
review we mean critical appraisal and or
analysis of shows and films not
discussion interview comedic
conversation watch along re-watch or
reaction content so this is why say the
jump gate podcast that I was doing with
Jesse gender that was uh on Babylon 5.
that is going to remain on hold because
that is considered re-watch content and
that sort of catalog show even though we
are talking about it in a kind of
reviews type way the nature of the
format it's not really structured as a
review and they would not consider as
such so that remains on hold we're
watching The Prisoner now if you aren't
already listening to the podcast feed so
that's fun uh the original version not
the Remake dear God no but anyway that's
why stuff like that will remain on hold
and it's why only reviews are going to
come back so there's a whole bunch of
other Doctor Who related well there's a
whole bunch of stuff related also to the
MCU Star Wars DC Etc but Doctor Who's
the most common one that I will continue
to not do I still won't be doing lists
and rankings I am not going to be
discussing uh any release of casting
information of plot
um reveals that have come out I'm not
going to do trailer reactions that kind
of stuff is still off the table but when
the specials for Doctor Who come out as
far as an actual review I watch it I sit
down and I tell you my thoughts on it I
give my critiques yes
that is back on and subsequently uh
classic Doctor Who reviews will resume
in the break room now if you care about
what I do Beyond Doctor Who how does
this impact other things well the main
impact of all this is still to the break
room of Geeks which is what has been had
having the the bigger impact there's
been a lot less stuff going up there
because most of what went up there was
review stuff and well review and trailer
reactions trailer reactions are still
out and the things that I had been
reviewing Episode by episode have
wrapped up and while I am going to catch
up on those things and some of them I
have finished doing so I don't intend to
go back and retroactively do Episode by
episode review thing uh reviews of
things that I would have done but
subsequently mixed uh not mixed missed
I'm my brain is not keeping up with my
mouth but uh in any case I'm not going
to do that largely just because I don't
have the time I don't have the time to
sink into doing individual episode
reviews for the five episodes of strange
new worlds that I could have been
reviewing but didn't and I do apologize
for the fact that my overabundance of
caution meant my opinions to these
things were not put forward that is on
me ultimately I made a call because it
was what I felt more comfortable with
rather than making a guess and risking
being wrong I now know that I could have
done those things but I'm not gonna I
don't have the time uh while I do still
intend to watch these I actually have
finished watching
um the final episode of secret Invasion
and I'm almost done now with strange new
worlds I don't plan to do individual
episodes on that
um so don't count on that as far as uh
upcoming stuff Episode by episode
reviews there isn't really much that's
on the immediate Horizon that I'm not
excited about I wasn't planning to watch
Ahsoka I'm not caught up on Lower decks
so like I don't know but theoretically
reviews of things that I've seen uh in
the theater or otherwise as long as it
is an actual you know as they put it
genuine review those will start
appearing on the break room again
as far as here the one thing that it has
a little bit of question of a question
mark on it and this question mark has
nothing to do with any vagueness on the
part of sagafra
but has to do with me getting over my
own Hang-Ups and issues so tiny bit of
vulnerability on this they do say that
analysis is also accepted you may have
heard me say that now
there is a whole category of stuff that
I do that probably well
definitely According to some people I've
already talked to fit under the category
of analysis
so this would be things like my dives
into say the uh queer reading of beyond
the spiderverse that was an analysis
that was a queer reading analysis of
that film and there are some things that
I've been planning on doing that would
also fit under analysis I mean honestly
I think some of my best work has been
analysis the video I did on Zack
Snyder's Watchman I'm still incredibly
proud of but
the thing is
regardless of what I know should count
uh there's this hang up of my own
comfort and unfortunately that Comfort
is being hampered by
lack of confidence in my own work
and I know this is my own hang up
I know that I have literally had people
tell who I've discussed this with tell
me to my face
that what you do when you do that sort
of thing is analysis it's covered it's
fine but the hang up is in my brain I
look at the size of my audience I look
at what I do and then I look at what
some of my peers who also do analysis
who do video essay style material do and
I look at what they do and I go I like I
have no business saying what I do is
like that
and that's
that's a self-confidence thing
that's a self-deprecating issue that's
some stuff I need to get over and I'm
gonna work on that and given how long
the strike is liable to last odds are I
probably will get a handle on that
um you know before the strike ends and
you'll get some analysis stuff but
give me some time
give me some time to just settle into my
own comfort
on that because look I've got Hang-Ups
about my own work and I tend to devalue
what it is I put out there just
instinctively probably
defensively if I don't think it's great
then if it doesn't take off or get
viewed much which most things I do don't
uh then it doesn't hurt as bad
bye
welcome to that glimpse into this mess
but regardless while analysis videos
might be a thing that start happening
again down the line and reviews
especially for stuff like the new
episodes of Doctor Who will definitely
happen keep in mind I still will not be
disgusting disgusting
brain and mouth disconnect again
discussing
things like casting announcements things
like
um new trailers things like just even
announced projects that fit into these
universes like Marvel and Star Wars and
DC I mean granted not a lot getting
announced right now but like that kind
of stuff that I might otherwise talk
about I'm just not going to and you know
lists rankings none of that and also
subsequently if you come to any of my
live stuff be it on Twitch or my
bi-weekly live here on this channel
um then
if you ask me for just a general opinion
on things that are struck work I'm still
not going to give it because me giving
my opinion in a stream is not the same
as doing a review so
please don't ask
um
but yeah
that's where things stand good news
overall
because
honestly the idea of not at least
reviewing the uh the upcoming specials
that was worrying me like I don't love
the idea of not talking about the new
Sonic Screwdriver that maybe I got uh my
own
um iteration of in and maybe I shot it
on I shot an unboxing video that maybe I
don't know when the hell that's gonna be
released I don't know that's a
theoretical possibility you know there's
there's stuff like that and like I don't
it's not the end of the world for me to
not have an immediate hot take on a
trailer or a story development that's
being hinted at in marketing Etc like I
don't need to have a take on that I
often do but I don't need to
the actual episodes like I like I kind
of need to like I was genuinely
concerned for
for my own State of Mind the idea that I
wouldn't be able to talk about them
which again overabundance of caution on
my part these are self-inflicted issues
I went further and was doing more than
they were asking me and and trying to
support the uh the strikes and I'm now
going to adjust some stuff is going to
be happening that I said a couple of
weeks ago or a week and a half ago about
that they wouldn't now they are it's
hopefully good news for people thank you
for your patience as I sorted out
getting clarification and I work on
sorting out my own comfort and my own
freaking brain
this is not an easy thing to work with
just saying
thank you for your patience thank you
for listening whatever your thoughts are
drop them down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables that uh despite my uh rank
thoroughly wrangled and labyrinthied
brain wrangled brain it's not wrangled
it's unwrangled you can't Wrangle it
it's unranglable this thing in here
despite that I am still able to pay my
bills thanks to things like the patreon
but um you know there's other things
down in the description I do don't worry
too much about all that what I want you
to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings
and reviews are back on
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
a special thanks to my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
look fulla Torah the thing that goes
Oink in the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures old Greg Bogdan Melinda Walters
Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks and
I'll be likes the poodle Robin Powell
traces rabbit angry Casper Adam RDO
Taylor Dave Hall and Rosalind Ben you'll
see a bunch of other names down there as
well there's plenty of things to get on
the patreon and yeah you can hear me
attempt to say your name without
embarrassing myself check out the
rewards and thank you for everyone who
supports this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]